hello and welcome to a video on
video editing with blender blender just
released
version 2.9 i thought it'd be a great
time to redo
my blender video editing basics video
so in here i'm just basically going to
show you that now i do have an app
running to show you what keys i'm
pressing and keys i'm clicking so on the
bottom
right you will see everything i do
there's like a left click there
right click and so on so obviously you
need to go
download blender and that is the base
requirement just blender 2.9 it should
work on any os
keys might be slightly different though
and once you're in blender you will get
your opening screen
you get this out of the way
and of course you got all this modeling
stuff
now to get to video editing there's a
couple different ways
you can click this plus up here at the
top
go to video editing and then video
editing again
and that takes you to the video editing
interface
you can also do or open a video editing
project specifically
by going to file new
video editing now you'll see you only
have video editing and rendering up here
now just a quick blurb about
why you should use blender or blender as
a video editor or why you could
it's basically it can do everything
it can do the stuff all the big editors
can do and it can do
pretty much all formats it does have a
few limitations
so let's get started now
the first thing you probably want to do
is your main
configurations and that's over here on
the right side
you want to make sure that
this output right here is set to where
you want your video to save
i don't want it to go to temp i would
rather go to a folder
see on my d drive called
render so i'm going to click that and
hit accept
accept again
and now it's going to save to that
folder so i know where to find it when
it's all done
and you want to scroll down a little bit
here
and change file format to ffmpeg video
there are other formats too or maybe you
actually do want a bunch of pngs
but in general you probably want a video
if you're video editing
there we go and then you also want to
check this
encoding drop down and scroll down some
and look for audio under audio you want
to change the audio codec
to aac and you can leave everything
alone
everything else here is optional you can
as you can see there are
options to do a bunch of different
things you're welcome to play around
with those but they
are just not required to get things
going and we're just looking at the
basics
now that you've got that started let's
go ahead and save in case something goes
wrong you don't want to have to redo
your settings so hit save
give it a title and as you can see it's
a dot blend file
we're just going to call this video
editing
long title i know and hit save
of course keep know where you saved it
now let's talk a little bit about
how to actually get a video in here and
how to
interact with this space a little bit
down here you see the sequencer
and if you're familiar with blender at
all you'll know that you can modify
these
as you want just by clicking on the
edges and dragging
and i don't want to talk about that a
whole lot because that's more of a
blender specific thing
but this is the default and we're just
going to stick with the default
on the sequencer if you hover over the
sequencer you can use your mouse wheel
to change your zoom you can hold your
mouse wheel down
to drag the sequencer
and a right click brings up a menu
and you'll see some things in here that
can help you once you're actually
editing
we may or may not use that left click is
what clicks things there's nothing in
here yet
let's go ahead and bring in a video
you'll see up here by default
that we have a file explorer you can use
this file explorer
to drag things in or bring things in you
can also just use
your operating systems file explorer to
bring things in
i'm going to go ahead and go to
my d drive by just typing it in there
and also use these buttons here to go
back forward up refresh
but on on my d drive i have a re a wreck
or recording
folder if you're bringing video in from
your phone you do need to bring that in
somewhere
and navigate to it
okay so we're going into the recording
folder and there's a bunch of various
videos
i'm just going to grab i guess this one
looks fine
and i'm just going to bring it down here
into the sequencer
there we go so now i can zoom out a
little bit
roll around by holding the mouse wheel
down
and kind of see the length of it and
getting to the end here you can look at
the top and see the times
now the first one is the minute seconds
here you see it's like 50 over here it's
getting to one minute
the second one after the plus is how
many frames when you really
oops when you really zoom in you can see
the frames more carefully
there's frame 40 there's frame 12
and also i should mention when you bring
in a video
it automatically sets up here in these
settings
the frame rate as you can see this set
it to 60
because this video was rendered at 60
frames per second
a really important thing here about
these frames is
it doesn't really do well with
videos of different frame rates so if i
now tried to bring in
a video recorded at 30fps it would not
work well together i would have to do
some like weird things
so it might be best to get them all in
the same format
before you bring them into blender to
edit them and there are other tools to
do that
such as handbrake and i believe
openshot video editor will put them all
in the same frame rate
so you could just do an export with
those or conversion with handbrake
but that's really a side point and
that's only necessary if you're
pulling video from different sources
different phones often record at
different frame rates
or if you're using recording software it
might be recording at different frame
rates
but i feel like that's necessary to
mention because i can get people caught
up
and now we want to scroll out so we can
actually see everything
keep scrolling out mouse wheel it all
centered up
and you'll see here there's an area
that's lighter
this this light area is where it's
actually rendering
and you can drag this playhead here
to view your video as you can see it's
kind of lagging as i'm going here
doing a lot of lagging i'm actually
clicking and dragging still
but it's just lagging and lagging and
that's
pretty normal it's because it has to
catch up and render this video as you're
dragging
now if you don't want to do that if you
don't want it to show your video
so you can actually work a bit faster
you can change this
preview or something else maybe just
another sequencer for this
moment now you can see when i drag it
super fast and responsive that can be
nice if you're editing
mostly off the audio now the audio track
is this bottom one
the teal one and you can click
over in the properties here
display waveform and that will show you
your actual audio waveform that way you
can tell maybe which points it's loud or
you're talking
or which points you want to cut because
it's too boring or something like that
it can often help to to see that
waveform
so i guess it's a good time to mention
that over here is where your properties
come up for anything you've clicked on
in your sequencer
if i click on the video i get this video
clip here
i get the properties of it if i click on
the audio
then i get the audio properties so most
videos do come
with an audio track and a video track
and you'll see some little tabs way over
on the side here that you can click on
to get other options sometimes you might
accidentally click on these
so just know to that if you're not
seeing the right options
check these tabs and make sure you're on
the right one i'm looking at strip
all right so let's actually change this
render area
to one we need because right now if for
example we hit play right here
you can hit play down here or you can
hit spacebar
it loops based on where you have it
starting and ending which can be nice if
you're working on an effect for that
little
little part and you can always change
these
at the bottom right here you see a start
and an end
these are frames so we're going to keep
the start at one
but we want to change the end to the end
of our video
so you can either click and drag
i guess my left button down thing is in
the way
but basically you see these wide arrows
it makes
you can click and drag there to change
it
and you can also just type it in
you can just go in there i guess i'll
get this over
for a second so those button things
aren't in the way
you can just physically type it in here
if you know exactly what frame it is
and it does tell you your current frame
of this playhead so
sometimes you can go off that for
example you can hit page up to go to the
end of the current strip
and then click this do a copy
and then paste it on the end and you get
the exact one that way
so now some basics you can cut this up
make parts shorter or longer whatever
you want to do with it
and i'm going to show you a little bit
of that and then i'll show you how to
render
you can also layer more videos
let's bring in another one
maybe you want clips from separate
videos so here's another one
we could like cut them and put it in the
middle but here to do this grab thing
i'm just
clicking and box selecting and then
clicking the clip and
left button down moving it pretty
straightforward operation there
you just click one of them and move it
and they get misaligned
now if you get them misaligned what you
can do is hit control z
go back standard undo and you can also
snap
so if you've got it like this if you
want to get it to line up
and you hold control it begins to snap
so it's trying to snap here and then
it's snapping over here
and that can help with the lineup too
that little snap option
let's say i don't know let's just do a
random example here
say i want to cut out some of this
so maybe the beginning maybe the
beginning of this first one is really
boring
so if you control click on an edge where
the edge is a slightly different color
you grab the edge and now when you click
and drag
on the left button down you actually
change the length at the start
maybe i want to cut off that part and i
click clicked out of here to unclick it
and i'll go to the end and do the same
thing
i'll hold ctrl and click
and as you can see it didn't grab both
that's because these clips are slightly
different
length now that tends to happen with
videos
sometimes the video and the audio or a
frame
different this is 1786
frames and this one's 1787. so i'm gonna
first grab this
and and just snap it to the end
now they're the same so when you control
click on things that i guess they're not
maybe okay this one needs to be
shortened
to 1786. now that they're both the same
length on the end
control click selects them both so
control click
will select everything of the same
length that includes uh
entire bars and if you're doing the end
it includes matching ends
so if i control click on this one they
also don't both select because they're
probably one frame off
a lot of recording software just tends
to do that
so maybe i want to go ahead and get that
one sorted out too
by changing this okay so now when i
control click
it selects them both so just a little
note on that control click to select
both
so we'll cut off a little bit of the end
on that one
and then say maybe we want to cut out
this middle part where it's a bit boring
now you notice i can't bring this play
head back here because it's
four zero that's just the way blender is
but if i move this up here and let's
move this other one out of the way
we can take our play head to here
and select both of these and we can cut
them you can do a right click and do
split as you can see it tells you the
hotkey
just k you see other options in here
like add transition
fade clear fade movie strip
make meta strip we're really not going
to get into those too much
but know that those are useful but
you're welcome to play around with them
just if you mess something up you can
always press ctrl z and undo what you
just did
so i'm going to do a ctrl click to click
both of these and i'm going to press
that k
shortcut and that now splits the clips
and we can interact with them as though
they're separate clips
so we'll just do a little playing around
here and drag the end of this one
so previously in blender to move clips
around you couldn't just left click
you used to have to press g for grab and
do it which still works
but now you can just click and drag if
they're selected so that's
one of the major changes in these this
new version
all right well the software i was using
to uh
do the key things has crashed so no more
of that i think you got the gist of it
though
okay so we're going to grab this end
here
and we'll move this over and if you
overlap
a little gets red and basically that
means it's going to snap out of there to
the end
so they are lined up now so a little
overlap is no big deal
you want to precision move these around
while you're dragging you hold
shift so holding shift it barely moves
but without holding shift it moves a lot
all right so that's looking okay we did
a few things maybe we'll throw in one
more cut here
so i'm going to highlight these press k
again
got some of this and there we go now our
clip is
split up if we want to see what that
looks like we can take
our i don't know let's just see how the
transitions look
we'll put the start right here
and we'll put the end
right oh right there
there and then we'll go up here and
change this to previewer
and it's going to kind of lag out
because it's actually got to load the
video
and we'll press space and now we can
kind of see what these transitions look
like
it does lag a little bit in the
transitions
and it's still lagging a bit it's pretty
normal for it to lag a little bit
when you're hitting play as you can see
it's bringing down this fps
also because i'm recording to this drive
i'm editing on
probably part of the reason why
so let's stop that there we go and you
can always render it out if you want to
see what something really looks like and
how it's going to render
you can go ahead and go to render
and render animation and it will render
that section that you have for the start
and end
let's say for example we just want to go
over here and add some of this other one
and i'll just do something random let's
do a display waveform
cut off some of the end
i'll go over here and cut some of this
okay move that over i'll cut some of
this
and we'll just drag it down here line it
up
drag it down here now someone's crazy
something kind of crazy happens when you
drag across
the playhead and it basically lags you
out like crazy
and that's because this preview is up so
you can either move the playhead out of
the way
or you can change this to sequencer
i'm going to change it to sequencer
because i'm not a big fan of that super
lag
move it down here move this down here
go ahead and change the end
um right there we're not going to worry
about getting it exact
middle click and drag over change the
start to here
and now we could render this out and and
get a little clip with all these cuts
but if we want to start getting fancy
here i'll show you a few more tricks
let's grab this here move it up a couple
i'll hold ctrl so it snaps and also
press
see why you're moving around you can
press x to stick with x
or y to stick on the y
nice little hotkeys there but what you
can do here
let me zoom in is you can
overlap them a little bit with the
previous one
and then click the video and the video
on the overlap and then
right click and go to fade or let's not
fade
transition and do a wipe a gamma cross
or a cross let's do wipe
so it adds a little wipe thing that's
the length of the overlap
you can go over here to the properties
while the wipe is selected
and you can change it there's some
transition types single
double iris clock and out blur width
angle and those are the main things you
want to mess with
but you can see what those look like and
get a little play around and
let me go to the preview previewer and
this is just the default
single wipe
now you couldn't really see it so i'd
have to render this out
i guess you can you can click and wait
for it to kind of lag
as you can see it's doing a wipe right
there in the middle
so if i change this same up the blur
with a little bit you can see how it's
blurring
or if i change this to double
you can see it's wiping on both sides i
guess the blur is kind of making that
hard to see
but you can see what your transition is
going to look like by just sitting here
and having it on the sequencer
and the volumes if you want the volumes
to fade you need to select both the
volumes
use shift to click both the volume so we
click the first one
hold shift click the second one then you
can right click
and go to crossfade sounds and that will
just make the sound so they don't
yeah just a standard crossfade and you
can do that with any clips where it
seems like it's a good idea
i don't know i guess it's up to your
video editing knowledge or video
producing knowledge
typically you don't want to crossfade
in between similar scenes usually it's
when it's going to a whole new
scene but this is just for the sake of
example so i'm going to delete this
and
maybe we want to
just back these up put it in there oh
they did something weird so i'm going to
hit ctrl z
ctrl z again there we go
it looks like it's just not um lining up
too well
there we go let's zoom out a little bit
i'm gonna box like all these move them
over
grab this put it there
and now this was a whole different video
over on this side so
maybe that's when we want the actual
nice transition
so we'll do a little overlap now the
typical good overlap length
is two seconds
that's just from my experience so if we
look on here we'll go
like 24 to this goes to about 25 and 36
we want like the 23 and 36
and we'll just drag it over to
approximately that maybe about
there it doesn't have to be perfect but
this is just a
general rule for them that tends to work
so
select both the videos again go to add
transition
wipe and try the fades to however you
want to do it
we'll do a wipe in with a
iris this time and we'll also go with
the sounds
and cross fade the sounds so that's
there's a lot of stuff you can play
around with
and then we'll line these last ones up
it's not seeming there we go i had to
click on them to move them
change the end to the actual end
and then when you're ready to render you
just go up here and click render
and it's going to take a while when it's
all done
you will find it in this location here
where you put it
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you